ah
[Music]
i am speaking to myself
through the corey malone
and atlas costumes
[Laughter]
wow
i have already spoken to myself through
the corey
atlas costumes on a previous episode
called a badass infinity
which was a great one at the retreat
shift into permanent alignment bentino
masara on the team where we met
which was great yes yeah that was that
was awesome
the whole thing the retreat and the
podcast was
crazy it's fun our friendship
are reuniting yeah
it's a breath of fresh air like i told
you earlier today
when i saw you on telegram it just
this fit you know it's fresh it was a
breath of fresh air is really nice
really nice to just
communicate and chat with people
that have the similar intention
because the seeking impulse dominated
the costumes life to the extent
at which then the costume
recognize that it is not just a costume
but it is that which makes all
costumes endlessly
and is that process
of costume making itself is also
illusory
exactly
so it of course is just one thing of
course it
we would just get together and feel good
yeah so of course these vibrations of
people that
get that instead of we've been talking
about this through the last couple of
episodes
when the i am meets
itself through costumes that know their
nature
it sounds like whoa
and when the egoic contracted
energies of person consciousness meet
it's like
[Music]
yeah that yeah yeah it's just
it just rubs against each other it
doesn't really fit
it doesn't fit because you haven't
molded it yet into
well it's like you haven't molded it yet
into who you truly are but then again
you haven't allowed it to be who you
truly are
so it's it's you know it's a back and
forth of
becoming who you are but then again just
shedding
more of who you're not yeah we just
talked about that with vg
yesterday on the episode where it's both
this
onion where you if so if
you're not raised by
a already enlightened
parents or by for example an indigenous
tradition that
raises the child right into infinity
from the beginning
you accumulate all of the onion layers
if
if you're born by ignorant parents
raised by them
and so what happens is you gain all
these onion layers and so that's why the
process
for many people is like shedding the
layers of identity and form
down to the nothingness and then also
it's the process of expanding from
person consciousness
to the cosmic consciousness to the
subtlety of
the great i am awareness as well as i am
the creator
right so it's the bothness of that
right which is awesome and crazy at the
same time
it's i feel like it's designed that way
to help you understand the paradox of it
you know it's what are the two pulls
the two pulls are nothing and everything
yeah
you can't go any more absolute than
nothing and everything
you can
and you know what is such a good feeling
is when you accept that
that it's nothing and everything and you
stop questioning like
why is it this or why is it that or
where are we coming from where does the
absolute come from like
that's just a human way of thinking
so when you really accept this and that
and
that that's it it's really liberating
yep and to to know
that i am that
i am the absolute i am
not separate from the absolute
this right here
timeless perfect being
is the absolute endlessly expressing
itself as everything possible and is
also
an illusion that anything's even being
expressed
just like in your dream at night when
you dream at night
and you simulate out a reality and you
simulate out an observer to experience
it and then you wake up in the morning
did the dream happen did the dream exist
was there a separate dreamed
reality that existed yeah
or was it literally nothingness
appearing
as a dream just like this yeah yeah
i love that dream analogy of how to
apply that to your waking life
that helped me a lot to actually
experience and to realize that
how you're not the body because when you
dream
you're just consciousness experiencing
that you don't actually
feel like you're a body doing these
things and flying around or whatever
you just experience it so
apply that to your waking life and
realize that's
actually what's happening it's literally
a dream
literally super relevant but a dream
and so that'll that can help you kind of
unhook from the body that that was a big
one for me kind of not
identifying with the actual body like
that that's who you are
and the dream is for the great i
am it's for the eternal
shared impersonal awareness right here
you i all 8 billion of these units
costumes are experiencing together
the shared collective dream
yeah and when you expand yourself out of
your person consciousness
into the subtlety of awareness and into
the subtlety of us
sharing our source and sharing our
awareness
that's when you really get to these more
elevated states of being able to
recognize oneself as everything as
nothing life flowing between those two
being beyond
even both of those just perfection
free timeless ineffable
yeah yeah and then you just laugh
because you know you're on that illusory
eternal
river yes yes
exactly you're on that just flowy
illusory
river and i like you just laugh
that's my fav honestly i think that's my
favorite part is just you laugh
you just lighten up and it's just
yeah it's everything's okay it's it's
it's not
serious it's fun it's fun
um but also there is an intention for
that
to come through to what you're meant to
hear in your calling like the calling
work we did
at the retreat the uh permanent shift
into alignment with bentino that
was the most profound thing i've ever
experienced was
you know accessing your calling as a
vibratory thing as a
unique essence of who you are in this
moment
what you want to give
as a energy
that was powerful so there's this
balance
between the illusory eternal
river which is literally trying to
find i was watching today osho talk
about this thanks to
vg he sent this over but he goes
i take your troubles seriously but deep
inside i am giggling
another one another one he goes
when i look at you i am searching for a
joke
oh so
be a joke on to yourself but at the same
time like you said
there's this divine transcendent
process of identifying what is my
calling how can i purify myself
so that i'm coming from god's love light
coming from a place of pure
service to others and then bringing that
gift that firework
and its greatest purity to
the collective yeah
yeah i think that's what makes it rich
that's what makes it juicy
you know you have that illusory eternal
river of flowiness and realizing
the i am and the absolute and it's
wonderful and it frees everything it
heals everything
but then you have this crazy calling and
this crazy anchor of why you're here
which makes it super rich and super just
in insanely powerful
and i love both of those expressions
it's
it it's phenomenal
which are which are ultimately one it's
very similar to the
yeah which is very similar to the
graphic that
i was talking about with bentino on the
very first night which is the graphic of
atlas that carries the world as
buddha is just chilling
nirvana on top of it and so the
you know and then bentino cracked the
joke and he and he goes
so i'm buddha and you're atlas carrying
me
and and i go well ultimately the two are
one
and then and then he's like ah you got
me there
and so it was it's good because he is
also atlas in that sense and i'm also
buddha in that sense and you're also
atlas
and buddha in that sense because we're
both liberated
from the cycle of birth and death we are
beyond
coming and going yet yet
we are also purifying ourselves towards
this calling of god's love light in
service to other people
at the same time
yes at the same yes
at the same time at the same exact time
man you got to send me those quotes from
uh oh show that
that's phenomenal i i've experienced
that a lot lately with talking to
talking to anybody and you know if you
hear
any anybody's problem or complaint
you just love them for who they are
okay so here's ah here's one of them
yeah oh nice yeah
i love that oh so when i look at you
i am searching for a joke and then
here's
here's the other one
okay here's the other one
ah oh wait let me hide that one
and let me add this one there we go
i take your trouble seriously but deep
inside i am giggling
huh
that's so good that's so good
those are the two quotes and then here's
another way to in a sense
uh for what we're talking about let's
see if i can
if i create a banner for this and then
if i click
s er
yeah this is right okay let's try this
nope this one
so in a sentence like buddha is like
this is a dream joke and the atlas
is like serious calling and ultimately
the two are one yeah
it'd probably be better
like this is probably better where you
where you can actually see uh
i tried getting a little hyphen in there
but i i it didn't show up
but yeah so there's stuff like that so
good
[Music]
nope still didn't show up like okay but
anyway yeah so there's
that that was a really good point though
because that's ultimately the
the illusory eternal river is your
cosmic
joke everything and nothing
simultaneously beyond coming and going
just absolute timeless ineffable
perfection
and yet there's this in you you do have
this process of these
individuated fractal secretions that
emerge as these costumes aka
the cory malone and atlas costumes that
then end up figuring out well what is my
calling what's my purpose here how do i
bring that gift firework
purely as god's love light and service
to others and so
i love that that was a that's a cool
little you know balance that's
ultimately won
yeah i i i'm in love with that balance
it's it's
it's fantastic because they both work
and
well it's both the truth so once you
experience it
um let me ask you something the calling
that you left with
at the retreat a couple weeks ago at
bentina's retreat
is that still resonating with you or has
it changed at all yeah for me
it's just so perfect because it allows
me to
be a jedi across all of the layers so
for me
my calling is people experiencing truth
and because of that
it enables me to be across the spectrum
from anywhere from person consciousness
to somebody experiencing themselves as
the creator
right so i i get that ability to sort of
navigate from the self-actualization
side as well as the self-realization
side right i get it
that's what's cool about people
experiencing truth
right so that that's for me why it's so
spot on how about you what was yours and
how do you feel now
it's still very much resonating and i've
checked in with it a lot
um mine is uh my calling is people
experiencing magic
and i just i get lit up by that i just
love
that feeling and i just love carrying
that around i love being
not even like a self-image thing because
i don't care about that
it's a question mark just be a question
mark as you roll through your life of
magic
of wonder just i just want to light
myself up as much as i can and offer
that to people
so yeah that's exciting to me and that
was a huge moment for me to connect with
that
[Music]
and it's cool because it's another one
of those that
people experiencing magic's a lot like
experiencing truth because in a sense it
enables you to be
across everywhere you can do
self-actualization self-realization
everything from upgrading person
consciousness
to cosmic consciousness from becoming
aware of awareness to becoming aware of
oneself as the creator
and that's what's really cool is the the
ability to say that
people experiencing magic is literally
any way
anywhere anytime yes yeah
yeah yeah that's really cool that you
said that because
you're right it's synonymous with truth
because magic is the nature of reality
yeah you know it's so it's just funny
you know isn't that funny how different
words resonate with it that word
specifically resonates with me
so yeah the way that
magic resonates for the corey costume is
the way that
truth resonates for the atlas costume
exactly and i'm also excited to oh sorry
um for you know
i'm sure it'll change you know because
your calling is ever
shifting it's not gonna be a one thing
for the rest of your life maybe but
it's exciting to just know that you you
know how to access that
yeah yeah that's why that's why
right away when i came back the first
video that i made is what is your
calling
on our channel because i wanted to share
with myself
to inspire myself across all these other
costumes that are
me on the channel that watch
me on the channel to me watching myself
getting me inspiring myself on the
channel
and that the capital s self across all
these costumes and so
because now you get a whole suite of
costumes that then recognize the
importance of this word calling and the
importance of this process
with recognizing what the calling is
yeah
yeah definitely yeah and i think that
can help a lot of
other selves or other quote unquote
people
really to just check in and and see what
resonates with them see what that unique
essence is
why you're here what what really lights
you up what
what excites you what what is that
feeling really what do you want to
experience most what do you want to see
other people experience most
and uh you can do that now you can do
that anywhere you can meditate on that
you could think about that
and that could be something very
powerful for you to shift into
so that's cool i'm glad you made that
video it's really cool i would say that
calling is probably also a little bit
more self-actualization driven and then
the illusory eternal river is more
self-realization oriented but they're
all again ultimately both
are are one but if you pursue
calling without knowing your true nature
you may pursue something
for a egoic kink
for a distortion like you you want to
get a watch
to be able to show off to other people
that
this unit has a material item um
type thing there's all these weird
distortions that come
from the process of self-actualizing
when you don't know your true nature
yeah definitely definitely because that
gives you the
the foundation to build on that and
it it's great because it's your calling
isn't a thing so if you want to be an
entrepreneur you have that dream
like bentino is saying let that be in
your wake
of the water let the let the expression
of the entrepreneur
happen but your calling is coming
through
always you're living that calling and
whatever needs to express will be in
that wake whether it's entrepreneurship
or music or whatever that expression is
so it's not
you actually being a musician or being
an entrepreneur
yes that's the expression of it but
checking with your calling is a
vibrational sense
uh that that that's what will carry you
there
yep so that's really that's really cool
and that's the breadcrumb trail of the
highest excitement
yeah yeah bashar and bentino
and so many others have talked about is
that
even tony robbins and all of the
self-help
psychology self-actualization literature
talks about that
same thing but again you have to come
from
a place of knowing your true nature
otherwise you and like even a simon
cynic
the infinite game are you playing a
finite game where are you playing the
infinite game because
if you're playing the finite then you're
going to want
something from maya you're going to want
peace or happiness for maya from the
illusion from the intoxication from the
dream
from a substance or an experience or
relationship but if you know your true
nature as infinite if you know yourself
as the subtle formless awareness
that i am that is shared in eternal
or even more so as that which even uses
awareness as its agent that
that absolute you as the creator
then you no longer see corey malone as a
separate
entity i see corey as
one of the costumes of i am and that we
are two costumes of the same source
talking to itself
and so then then everything i do comes
from a place of
purely and again it's the purifying
process it's not overnight i decondition
all of my [ __ ] right so yeah so
we're going through a process right now
basically
as continuing the team talked about
anurag and richard talk about this too
which is basically like it's a [ __ ]
navy seals boot camp
it's not it's not a gym membership
this is some navy seal [ __ ] because you
basically have to become vigilant about
every single frame of your life
like like earlier today
like i i made the declaration at the
retreat right i made this declaration
where i said that
i will no longer experience selfish
gratification when helping people
experience truth
and that was a big [ __ ] deal for me
because i wasn't
aware of the fact
that that was happening until i really
made the declaration and now guess what
today while i was helping people i
i recognized the two the two
timelines where i saw on one timeline
the conditioned atlas
unit i was watching that conditioned
atlas unit receiving
selfish gratification from helping
somebody experience truth and on the
other timeline
i witnessed my shift into permanent
alignment
which is that whoa this is what i want
from now on which is
that i see my [ __ ] i see my
fraudulence
i see that fraudulent ass conditioned
timeline
and that's [ __ ] and i'm not that
anymore i am just the gods love light
timeline
i am just recognizing that i'm serving
myself
to know the true nature and that
it's coming from a place of purity so
that subtle distinction it was such a
subtle
[ __ ] distinction
yeah it was so subtle and it just
continues to happen like that now after
the declarations
what was your declaration too
my declaration was um i declare
to live from my heart
because i think i had a lot of [ __ ]
stories
and full of [ __ ] about just a lot of
things just
how i come off to people wanting to be
this way or that way or
you know and it just i don't it doesn't
matter
like whatever is true for my heart which
is true for the creator coming through
me
and and then that's what i want because
it'll be better for everybody
it'll be more beneficial for everybody
in the sense of what we're talking about
here so
that was my declaration to live from the
heart instead of from
an egoic sense instead of from well how
can
how could i show up or how do i look to
this person or
am i looking cool right now or but all
these stupid thoughts that are
so silly um so yeah it's
that was mine and and it's been really
nice checking with that but i like what
you said about it being subtle because
it really is
it's not like a profound ooh i'm living
by this now it could be
sometimes it is but it's super subtle
when you
deepen these layers it's like wow it's
just like a thin layer
of [ __ ] [ __ ] that i'm dealing
with that i want to
purify what we both declared was
basically the same intention
worded differently just like people
experiencing truth versus magic
just like yeah really cool because you
described this hyper similar process
where
when if there's there's only one of you
and that one of you is declaring
that i'm only gonna live from god's love
light which is the exact same thing that
i was just declaring and talking about
versus that slightly that one onion
layer that's left
of that egoic condition psychology that
that impurity that's left that wants to
like you said
that it wants to have cory malone be
something special for other people to
see
or something like that and that's very
similar with what i was saying was
feeling gratification when helping
people experience
truth yeah definitely i think
on this road of finding
you know the nature of reality finding
who you are
self-realization because it's such a
process of
unlearning the ego gets to that point
where like well i've done
so much work that i need to be
validated for that or i need to be
special for all the work i've done
the years i've put in for this the years
of
awakening and all this stuff whatever
you want to call it whatever word you
want to say
i need to feel special so that's where i
think it becomes subtle you're like no
it's not that's not it and there's more
at least for me i experienced that like
i put in so much work
into it but yeah i need to
yeah that was perfect too we had
bentino at the retreat say that
to purely be in service to others
you're gonna have to deal with a lot of
not being seen
right so you're gonna have to deal with
a lot of not being validated for being
in pure service to others
good [ __ ] deal with it
me me too i'm on that same train
where it's like i don't need your
validation
for me to just radiate like the sun does
the sun get thank yous from the trees
you know no no does the sun stop
shining if it goes oh well that person
or that tree is not appreciating me that
tree's in the shade
so i'm not gonna shine anymore no it's
just constantly shining no matter what
that is like one of the
best analogies for this it is just keep
shining
without expecting any fruits that's the
key karma yoga right no
fruits no expectations and just keep
going at the roots
endless roots endless roots endless
roots
and naturally harmony will unfold
just so unbelievably ineffably
perfectly that if you focus on the
fruits
you will feel so much disharmony you
will feel so much
yeah yeah it's like the carrot dangling
in front of your face you can
you know it you can get stuck in that
loop but you realize
you are the fruit you are you are it
yeah you are also that which is going to
enjoy what ends up being the fruits
as you work on your roots non-stop but
you have absolutely zero
attachment to the fruit yeah which
europe
yeah which in which in this case it's
this mission of
we we catalyze this planetary
enlightenment and we do so with zero
attachment whatsoever
to the process uh and to the outcome
and that we just surrender to
the hydrological cycle that we
are we are that fractally romanesco
broccoli
happening you know have you seen you
know you're aware of that yeah
no but i love that you said romanesque
broccoli
it's this yeah here i'll i'll show i'll
show it to the
sauce
you you you are basically this
yeah like the i am is basically
this and then you have like the little
corey malone one and the little atlas
one and the little bentino
and yeah and whatnot like these are
these are the little costume expressions
all of these endlessly costume
expressioning
and you're also that's the eternal river
and then you recognize that there was
never even
a romanesque broccoli fractaling um
yeah shit's hilarious it's
it is it is hilarious
oh my yeah wow
yeah so that's that's it and there's
there's so many
other um
little examples of
the
the golden ratio
in nature right and if you start
if you really start uh let's do this one
again
you know if you really start looking
let's see if i can zoom in on this
there we go this one oh there you go
right like this is
your endless emergence as
galaxies and hurricanes and
nautilus shells and sunflowers and
romanesco broccoli and also as humans
like we are the same
secretion we just have self-awareness
and choice
which is what makes human experience so
dope
and highly sought after and basically
the
playland of creativity and creation
and at the same time this is all a dream
so yeah i love these images here it's so
cool to see that
it's like the shell sunflower
it's just all reflecting reality
or you know what's really the truth
it's beautiful hurricane too that's cool
yeah this is the this is the eye
here's another sort of
way of viewing it it's like the universe
logarithmic scale and so when you look
up
uh you know universe logarithmic scale
right what does
what does what what you know what does
that what does that scream to you
you know that's a [ __ ] pupil an iris
right there
[Music]
yeah that's a [ __ ]
yeah wow that's her pupil and iris baby
i love that see if i can get that yeah
cool cool
and you'll never come to the
end of all of the different ways that
you create
universes and then immerse yourself into
them
as different costumes and
yet at the same time you'll always
recognize that these are
just dreamed explorations and that
you're also absolute void shunya
stillness behind
and beyond at all
definitely that's such a cool image i
love this
i love this so cool yeah it's like
you're looking at your head it's look at
somebody in the eye
and you can just see that yeah
this as a buff so below so you have the
phenomenon of the universe
logarithmically that looks just like
our own bel as so below
the pupil and the iris
this is the this is basically the great
i am
this is the first attribute of the
absolute awareness
this is it that's
it's yeah first attribute the sprout
from awareness
boom from absolutely from the absolute
and then
it sprouts at from that great i am into
all of these
vocalized iambs
you have all of these costumes that are
part of this grand
great i am that literally
has the pupil iris just like we have the
pupil iris
so at this scale just like you know you
and i
our costumes share the same pupil but we
have different irises that's why you
have your
unique corey malone costume and i have
this atlas costume
that's the iris right which is the
difference the uniqueness
but the pupil is the sameness does that
make sense
definitely and then yeah and then
similarly at the universal level
you have the pupil stays the same
always it's awareness but the iris is
like the unique coloration
of the universe as in the universe here
took on this role as this planet
with eight billion units orbiting the
star with the specific
civilizational history with dna
carbon-based life forms that have two
eyes and four limbs and [ __ ] like that
and that it just constantly changes so
the iris also changes
endlessly on the universal level
wow yeah i like that that's really cool
man it just it's just so many layers to
the illusion because at the same time
it's like
there's not even any densities because
if if
the the atlas costume the corey costume
we're just
one there's really no anything there's
no evolution really it's just to put it
into context
it's just you go yeah
you're that just got me thinking a lot
about uh
how many layers of the illusion is
actually occurring
subtle
yeah like this is a pretty this is a
pretty bold
you know you let's put it on the screen
right there boom
you know this is a pretty bold statement
and
it's really difficult for
people to grapple with it when they
haven't
experienced nothingness simultaneously
with
everythingness because there is both no
evolution from the place of absolute
stillness void
shunya nothingness and is we're just
putting
life into context by explaining
evolution and densities
and yet at the same time there is
i went from a zygote to a 30 trillion
adult that's wearing this atlas costume
and that that is also my direct
experience of being this firework that's
went through
this process so that's the simultaneity
and can you go beyond both
yeah yeah definitely it's like this
again
buddha cosmic joke atlas
serious calling buddha
cosmic choke stupid
which are ultimately one they ultimately
merge into one
just one i take your trouble seriously
but deep inside i am giggling
that is so good i love that quote let's
hide that one oh this one's a ticker
when i look at you i am searching for a
joke
and then this one is also from the
episode we did with
gilad hillary and gina there is only one
intelligence present we put that one up
i love that i love that it's such a good
one
that's so good so
good it's only one and i think that
part of the reason that why people may
find it difficult for the the wellness
con the oneness and the no evolution
thing we just were talking about is
because of
conditioning of hierarchy conditioning
of this and that conditioning of your
life
going from this to that you know when
when like bashar talks about
we're shifting through billions of
parallel realities
that are static every second
so if they're static then
how is there any sort of
this then that or any sort of continuity
is what
i was trying to do non-linear
static shifts yeah every thing that we
do
is a permission slip yeah
[ __ ] into the reality we shift into by
both of us
going to the shift into permanent
alignment retreat we shifted into a
completely new reality
yeah 100 and that's the insanity of all
of these
simultaneous timelines because you can
literally
watch you know the little atlas unit in
its
timeline that was
you know let's say you've gotten rid of
you know the bottom
decisions and you're left with just
these sort of
two that are aiming up towards this
north star over here
this calling and one of them one of them
is this one which is a lot more
directly pointed at it and this one is
like also pointed at it but a little bit
lower
and you can watch the corey malone unit
you know go
renege on this on these commitments and
like there that corey malone unit like
you can watch that timeline go
and you you're left with just what your
higher self your higher your highest
excitement
is in this specific
exploration that you're undergoing
definitely yeah definitely
when did you book the retreat
did you book it a while out or was a
last minute thing for you
oh it was like you know like 10 days or
something out yeah
you yeah it was like honestly about the
same it was like
two weeks two and a half weeks before
yeah i woke up with this
feeling like wow this like
in my chest i could feel it this
unfulfillment feeling
and instantly he was like you need to go
this retreat
and so i booked it that day yeah exactly
yeah
that's crazy and amazing
for me for me it was not necessarily
like a feeling of
something that needed to be fulfilled it
was
more it was more like
i wanted to further refine
that
already incredibly refined understanding
of the nature of reality
and that i had been watching bentino for
quite some time and i wanted to
get a darshan as a set you get the
direct
sort of enlightenment transmission and
then also the surrounding
that container all the retreated all
this type of stuff
and it was basically just this
unbelievable sort of like
this is exactly what like come go like
again let
you know and it was just the perfect
amount of
of you know financial you know right
back down to
you know you go from like having like
just out of
out of the out of the blue you get you
know you're
when you've normally been at like 500
bucks in your account you get your 4 500
bucks
and then you spend boop 4 000 on the
retreat and you're back to your 500
and like it's just like the perfect
increase to be able to spend it
all on that type thing and it was just
like ridiculously aligned it was just
perfect oh perfect
absolutely it's just like you take this
step and the floor appears
that's such a beautiful way of just
looking at it and living just just
follow your
excitement and then the uh the step will
appear for your foot
it'll be placed right there for you
instead of going
well let me go to this way or these
stairs or that
no no don't calculate anything just do
it
from what resonates with you yeah
just true trust yes
yes
i was gonna say that's the multiverse
and then here's all of your
potential colors of all of the
expressions
oh my god amazing let's wrap with a
little abiding session
okay all right cool
all right everyone we invite you
to relax
use your breath
relax back
into the very fact
of i exist
into your very timeless being
use the breath as the tool for your gym
repetitions
to bring yourself back to awareness
itself
beingness itself
stop describing your experience stop
symbolizing your experience
and recognize how you become more
formless
immediately you become more formless you
drop
the identity the descriptions the
symbolization
the form the costume
the separation and you melt into this
formlessness
and that formlessness that is shared
that is eternal
that very source fullness
and check in with yourself like this
throughout the day
dropping into that sourcefulness itself
the perfect timeless ineffable
the background nectar
omnipresent
the eternal river
that is also not happening
know yourself as beyond coming and going
know yourself as beyond birth and death
know yourself as
beyond nothingness and everythingness
just ineffable perfection
uh
[Music]
beautiful do you have some thoughts
you'd like to add corey
i think that was perfect that was
perfect
perfect conclusion i love that
i feel good about that
ah the
the i am is
[Music]
playfully blissfully joyfully peacefully
excited about the interaction between
the
atlas and corey costumes
[Music]
all right beautiful
yeah so beautiful yeah okay okay let's
let's close it out all right thanks
everyone
we love you love everyone thank you
atlas i appreciate it
thank you thanks for joining us and let
us know your thoughts in the comments
the other costumes in the i am
we'd love to hear from you and
like the video if it brought you value
helps the
algorithm subscribe if you haven't share
the video with those that you feel like
this would resonate with
my gosh there were so many good things
in there
we had so many so much good as a buff so
below in there
the buddha and atlas ultimately won how
you take your serious calling and you
simultaneously
hold that along with the cosmic joke and
there's so many good things in there
that was
such a good convo all right infinite
love
thanks everyone awesome all right you
and i will stay in here hold on i'm
gonna end it
perfect